MARTIN OMANDER: Hi, Dina.
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN: Hi, Martin.
How's it going?
MARTIN OMANDER: Going
great, because today, we
are designing an application
that deals with money, I hear.
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN: Oh.
Oh yeah, that's true,
for our event planners.
MARTIN OMANDER: Right.
So it's going to be a
serverless application that
deals with money.
We're going to go through
exactly what products you
use in this thing.
Are you ready?
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN: I am.
MARTIN OMANDER: Let's do it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN: OK.
So we have three users.
We have our event planners, our
accountants, and our vendors.
And our event planners need
to register the vendors.
They need to create
purchase orders
so that the vendors
deliver whatever
it is that they're delivering.
The accountants need to
view and approve invoices
so the vendors get paid.
And the vendors need to be
able to submit their invoices.
MARTIN OMANDER: Very good.
So I see we have them here
on the left-hand side.
Looking good.
And let's see.
Some of these are
inside our company
and some are outside, eh?
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN:
Yes, exactly.
We can think of this
as like two groups.
One is internal and
one is external.
MARTIN OMANDER: Got it.
And the internal
ones-- that's, it
looks like, event
planners and accountants.
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN:
Yeah, exactly.
So, we're going to
build a web app.
But yeah, it's worth
starting by thinking,
how are we going
to ensure that only
the people inside our
company access this web app?
MARTIN OMANDER: Ah, right.
So for a project
I recently was on,
we used identity-aware
proxy for that.
It is super simple
to set things up.
People within our
domain, they get in.
Everybody else is kept outside.
And you can even set
levels within that.
But yeah, for this, super easy.
Let's do it--
Identity-Aware Proxy.
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN: Awesome.
OK, so the next question is,
what do we use for the web app?
MARTIN OMANDER: Yeah.
So web app-- OK, serving
HTML, JavaScript, and so on.
I think App Engine
would work well here.
You and I both know
App Engine well.
It's also-- again,
on my last project,
it was like a two or three click
integration to put it together
with Identity-Aware Proxy.
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN: Even
better and super classic.
Love it.
OK.
Whoa, this is easy.
MARTIN OMANDER: So we're done.
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN: We're done.
No.
Next, we come to possibly
the first difficult decision.
We have to start thinking about
storage, because the event
planners are going to
be filling out a form
and saying these
are the vendors,
and that needs to go somewhere.
And I like to think
about storage options
always as relational databases
versus nonrelational databases.
And in this case,
we're talking about--
we're talking about money.
We're talking about, these
are the purchase orders
and then these are the
invoices, and we're
going to need to be able to run
reports against these things.
Say like, this is like
the money that we pledged.
This is the money that we paid.
And so for something
like that, I really
think that we absolutely have
to use a relational database.
MARTIN OMANDER: Yeah, I agree.
Like you're saying, sum
up like 1,000 documents,
1,000 invoices, and get their
sum-- super easy and quick
to do.
And I think we could do Spanner.
We could do various
other things.
I think Cloud SQL is
right here, because we
will have on the order of
gigabytes and not terabytes
or petabytes here.
So Cloud SQL, which
is well-known.
You and I are both familiar
with MySQL and Postgres,
so that'll be easy.
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN: Oh my gosh.
I feel like it's 2010.
App Engine with a
Cloud SQL database?
I love it.
MARTIN OMANDER: [LAUGHS] Yeah.
Well-known technology.
OK, cool.
So let's see.
Everybody's got-- oh no.
Vendors aren't
connected to anything.
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN: Yes.
OK, so the first thing
that we need to think about
is the fact that
they are external
and they're coming from anywhere
and possibly everywhere.
So how do we ensure that they
are able to access our service
and do appropriate things on
the service, but nobody else is?
MARTIN OMANDER: Right.
So we need to know
that they are who
they say they are and so on.
I think for that, Identity
Platform is a great choice,
because then they can login
with their Gmail accounts,
or from various other identity
providers, they can login.
It's self-service to
setup their own accounts.
But we do know who is who.
If somebody logs in as
fluffybunny@gmail.com,
we know that that
really is fluffybunny,
the vendor, or
sonomawinery.com, maybe.
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN:
More likely.
MARTIN OMANDER: Yes.
[LAUGHTER]
So Identity Platform there,
I think that's a shoo-in.
That would be easy to do.
But now what platform serves
up HTML and JavaScript
and CSS to them?
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN: Yeah.
I think let's go with
App Engine again.
I don't think that we need
to do Cloud Run for this
because we're not using
any special runtimes
or anything like that.
I think just your standard
App Engine would work great.
MARTIN OMANDER: Yep.
I agree.
I love Cloud Run,
but it's smarter
to keep it to only one
product here for computing.
OK, so these folks
upload invoices.
It says here,
submit invoice PDF.
Is that what the
vendors are doing?
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN:
[SIGHS] Yes.
OK, so we always
need to consider
that we need to meet our
users where they are.
And, in this case,
our event planners
work with vendors from
all over the place.
Sometimes, it's like
a giant hotel chain
that has very standardized
systems that can plug and play
really easily with
whatever we want.
And then sometimes, it's mom
and pop from a Sonoma vineyard
and they're going to
maybe send their invoice
on the back of a postcard.
I don't know.
[LAUGHTER]
Or they even fax them sometimes.
So yeah, we need a
system that allows
the vendors to keep using
whatever system works for them.
Maybe it's a PDF.
Maybe they have a
handwritten invoice.
And it'd be really
cool if they could just
take a picture and upload it.
MARTIN OMANDER: Yeah,
with their phone, right?
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN: Yeah.
Yes.
Yes, exactly, which means we're
back to the storage question.
But this time, it's
not columns and rows.
It's not numbers.
It's bytes.
It's rather difficult decision.
MARTIN OMANDER:
Binary files, right.
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN: Yeah.
MARTIN OMANDER: And we could
theoretically store them
in a relational database.
But there are products that
are better at it, right?
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN: Yes.
Yeah.
And we don't want to store
them for too long, either.
So I was thinking that
maybe we could use something
like a Cloud Storage bucket.
MARTIN OMANDER: I love that.
Google Cloud
Storage, because you
said we don't want to keep
them around for too long.
On a previous project I
worked, we set things up so
after six months--
you can do this
very easily with a few
clicks in Cloud Storage.
After six months,
delete the files.
So it's nice and clean.
Everything's automated.
You have automated controls.
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN: Yep.
Yes.
MARTIN OMANDER: This is good.
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN:
Yes, and you
can set kind of like granular
permissions per storage bucket.
So I think using Cloud
Storage is really great.
Are we done?
MARTIN OMANDER: All right,
so the vendor took a picture
with their cell phone
of the postcard they'd
written their invoice on.
They send it up.
It's now sitting in a storage
bucket in Google Cloud Storage.
Now what?
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN: We need to
get this data from the bucket
somehow into Cloud SQL.
So we don't want to have
a system where somebody's
got to login and look
at all these images
and then input it into
a form, because, well,
what's going to
happen is it's just
going to take for take forever.
It's going to sit there
for a really long time.
People are going
to make mistakes.
And then the vendors are
going to get really angry when
their payments are super late.
So I think we need
to do some kind
of event-driven
development here,
so that as soon as the image
goes into the storage bucket,
something happens that
starts us on our pipeline
into the Cloud SQL.
What do you think?
MARTIN OMANDER: OK.
Yeah, I like that.
And we can easily setup a
Cloud Function to do that.
So if a new document
drops in this bucket,
then trigger this
Cloud Function.
And the Cloud Function gets the
document so it can work on it.
OK, so the Cloud
Function now has
access to this image taken
in-- a PDF or image taken
with a phone.
And now we need to
pull data out of that.
How do we do that?
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN:
With machine learning.
MARTIN OMANDER: Of course.
I like your enthusiasm, but I'm
not really a machine learning
expert, Dina.
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN: Oh
my gosh, neither am I.
But the great thing is,
you don't have to be.
Now we use machine learning,
not just because it's cool
and because it's a buzzword.
Machine learning
is the tool to use
when you need to make
decisions on things that you
don't know about yet.
You have seen examples
of it in the past
and you need your system
to be able to look at it
and make a decision
without having
an exact recipe, a list
of steps to follow.
And so this is a
perfect example.
Because we don't
know what fields
are going to be on
this form, we don't
know if they're
going to be writing
little handwritten
messages with hearts on it.
So we need some kind
of machine learning
API to be able to go in
and parse the information.
Now luckily, Google
has a lot of products
that already have
prebuilt models for you,
because I do not want
to go in and build
my own model for this.
MARTIN OMANDER:
Google has probably
seen far more documents
than you or I have seen
or can come up with, yeah.
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN: Exactly.
Exactly.
And I don't have the time to
collect a million examples
to be able to train a new API.
So I think we should
use the Vision API,
because the Vision
API has a feature that
lets you parse forms.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh excellent.
Cool.
So Vision API there.
We run that, and then the
output of that is like--
it can tell things
like tax was $100,
the total was $500,
that sort of thing?
It'll pull its properties?
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN:
Exactly, exactly.
So it'll go through and
it'll find the labels
and then it'll find the values.
And then you have
this structured data.
But the only thing
is, we need to be
careful about trying to put
this directly into something
like a relational
database because we don't
know all the fields
that are going
to be on the form in advance.
MARTIN OMANDER: Ah, right.
I think I have just
the right thing.
So we have documents
with certain properties.
We don't know exactly
what properties.
There is a database product
built for that, Firestore.
It's a document database.
So each document can
have different properties
from other documents, as well.
So it's sort of semi--
it's more ordered
than just an image,
but is not as strictly
ordered as a SQL database.
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN: Perfect.
Perfect.
OK, so then we have the event
triggering the Cloud Function.
The Vision API looks
at it and says, hey,
this is the name of the event.
This is the vendor.
This is how much it costs.
It puts all of that
into Firestore.
And then when our accountants
log onto our App Engine web
app, we'll pull up that document
from Firestore Firestorm,
and then they'll be
able to look at it
and they'll be
able to approve it
or to be able to
edit it slightly.
Maybe look at the image
and say like, oh no.
This wasn't for Mom
and Pop Vineyard.
This was for Sonoma.
I don't know.
[LAUGHTER]
MARTIN OMANDER:
Right, or one image,
one number was a little smudged.
And then in that one out of 100
cases, they can go in and tweak
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN: It.
Yeah.
MARTIN OMANDER: I like that.
And that would do
that from App Engine.
And you said then that
feeds into SQL, right?
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN:
Then we're done.
MARTIN OMANDER: Yay.
I like this.
It's sort of order out of chaos.
Chaotic data comes
in and gradually gets
more ordered along the way.
And finally, it's ordered
enough for the accountants
to issue a payment.
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN: Yeah Yeah.
No, the great thing is
that there's these two
different work streams.
One is just your very, very
classic App Engine Cloud SQL.
And the other really
takes advantage
of all of these
new event-driven,
and machine learning,
and Firestore,
and all these new technologies
and ways of coding and ways
of thinking.
And then we put them
together and, like you
said, order out of chaos.
MARTIN OMANDER: Thank you,
everybody, for watching.
If you would like to
see me or Dina design
another serverless app, please
let us know in the comments,
or if you have questions
about this one.
Also, let us know
what other topics
you would like to see
in this video series
about serverless computing.
Until next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]